in the past only the paranoids survived
but in the present only the optimists
Thrive given the fact that you can't
predict the future you have to have some
sort of fantasy about how the world's
going to go and that fantasy can either
be negative or positive so why not pick
one that's enjoyable just pick one that
makes the world seem a little bit Rosier
and assume that the glasses are full and
this is so wild for me to say because
six seven years ago I was very
conservative very risk averse but it
wasn't just showing up in my actions it
was showing up in the way that I
perceived the world too whereas now it's
kind of like prepare for the worst hope
for the best is kind of I guess how I
would set myself up still in terms of
actions very risk averse but in terms of
the way that I see the world pretty
optimistic and pretty hopeful